the vegas golden knights because they
start their quest for the cup tomorrow
afternoon
against dallas they'll head into the
postseason without max pacharetti
but with robin leonard in goal kevin
martin with more on the excitement of
the vegas golden knights
first meaningful game in nearly five
months this group
deserved an opportunity to compete for a
stanley cup
for a while it seemed this golden
knights team wasn't going to get that
chance
but now less than 24 hours out from
playing in their first meaningful game
in almost
five months head coach pete deboer is
relieved
you only get so many of those
opportunities so you know had we not
got the opportunity this year would have
been a shame you know that this group
didn't get that chance to compete for it
so
you know my biggest feeling
is is just relief the knights who won 11
of their last 13 games before the paws
positioned themselves as one of the top
four teams in the western conference
giving themselves a little bit of
breathing room by avoiding the
nail-biting best-of-five qualifiers
i knew these three out of fives would be
you know
literally dog fights right from
day one and you're already seeing i
think there was 212 seeds that
that that one game won so uh you know
you're happy not to be involved in
in that you're happy you get a little
more runway before
uh your first series and you're happy
that that first series is a four to
seven
and as for the players they're fired up
to start round robin play
even inside an empty arena i think we
expected the worst it was
really weird but for me it was it was a
little different don't get me wrong but
i think it was pretty good for a
preseason game and then you watch those
first couple games
you know once once one guy scored you
just see how much energy you know one of
the ice and the bench has and
that's just what playoff hockey does
kevin martin ate sports now
all right thank you kevin a busy week
for the nights now it begins monday with
the stars wednesday against st
louis saturday they face colorado